[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je tout d'abord je vous dis bonjour je
me présente je suis donc isabelle kassi
fofana
je suis comme la dame vient de
l'indiquer présidente d'une association
l'association akwaba culture
je suis également directrice fait
l'interdition donc j'ai voulu
véritablement de le domaine du livre
depuis près de vingt ans ça ne rajeunit
pas mais c'est la vérité
alors aujourd'hui je voudrais vous
parler avec avec mon coeur c'est ce que
je disais aux autres speaker j'avais
préparé quelque chose je dis bon ya pas
de pupitre et tout mais c'est je pense
que c'est c'est mieux que je vous parle
comme ça avec le coeur je vais vous
faire donc partager mon expérience
quand je suis parti de rien de rien mais
j'avais j'avais l'amour de ce que je
faisais je suis tombée follement
amoureuse de du livre et de la
littérature et dont je me suis dit
qu'est ce que je pouvais apporter
qu'est ce que je pouvais faire j'ai
travaillé en tant qu'attachée de presse
dans une maison d'édition de la place
c'était à l'époque la plus grande maison
d'édition
j'ai commencé donc au bas de l'échelle
et puis donc à force de lire ml
puisqu'il fallait que j'aille les
présenter à la télé et ailleurs j'ai
commencé à vraiment apprécier ce que je
faisais et je me suis dit bon qu'est ce
que je devais faire
ces vins que j'ai évolué lentement mais
sûrement dans cette maison d'édition
je suis passé chargé de communication
ensuite responsable communication et jeu
j'avais eu l'occasion d'aller dans des
salons un peu partout mais je suis dit
c'était pas ce n'était pas suffisant et
je suis parti d'une idée très simple
dans le cadre de mon métier je devais
mettre en lumière les auteurs et les
ouvrages de notre catalogue et j'ai donc
je participais à des prix littéraires et
je me suis vite rendu compte que tous
les prix littéraires qui devait donc
récompensé nous nos auteurs africains
étaient logés en europe ce qui n'est pas
une mauvaise chose en soi parce que ces
prix littéraire je vais parler par
exemple du grand prix littéraire
d'afrique noire du prix des cinq
continents du prix ahmadou kourouma et
j'en passe ces prix littéraire na ont
révélé des talents
ces prix littéraire on nous ont permis
de mieux connaître nos auteurs africains
et certains de ses auteurs la hoya
occupé deux grands postes les postes
ministériels et tout ça depuis les
années 1960
je parlais des ces innovations kouyaté
et j'en passe mais on a dadié qui était
qui ont été révélés par par ces prix
donc notamment le grand prix littéraire
d'afrique noire mais j'étais frustré
parce que je me suis dit bon est-ce que
ça va continuer jusqu'en 2000 jusqu'à
voilà c'était bien que que nos frères et
amis européens nous aident à promouvoir
nos auteurs africains mais pourquoi pas
nous à partie du continent
on pouvait pas on n'était pas à même de
créer un prix littéraire aussi important
qui partirait de l'afrique pour les
africains avec nos sensibilités
on était quand même un même de juger de
la valeur intrinsèque des ouvrages donc
seule idée venue comme ça mais il
fallait j'avais pas de moyens j'avais
rien du tout et il fallait je pouvais
pas aller seuls deux pour réaliser ce
rêve il me fallait convaincre quelques
personnes ressources ce que j'ai fait
donc là ce soir akwaba culture que j'ai
l'honneur de diriger est constitué de
quatre membres
donc tous talents on va là on va les
montrer dans le la présentation
powerpoint que j'ai eu à
avisé il nous fallait convaincre et
ensemble 4 pourquoi parce qu'en général
les associations quand on est trop
nombreux mais on a tendance à vouloir se
voit là à se glisser des peaux de banane
alors que là il faut retrousser les
manches et travailler
donc on est resté à 4 et voilà chacun
savait qu'il fallait que j'y joue sa
partition et avec les réseaux les
relations qu'on a pu avoir si l' on a
lancé le prix ivoire pour la littérature
africaine d'expression francophone dont
la petite histoire qu'on n'avait rien
même pour le lancement
j'ai dû emprunter 500 milles quelque
part avec quelqu'un je suis allé voir à
l'époque un directeur du livre il m'a
dit isabelle j'ai pas d'argent mais je
peux te prêter la salle de conférence du
ministère de la culture et de la
francophonie
puisque tu dis prix ivoire c'est quand
même voilà c'est ce que je peux faire
pour toi mais pardon bon hein
si tu viens quand même le cocktail et où
j'ai pas d'argent faut pas dire que
c'est vous qui allez payer
j'ai tout qui a pas de problème tu me
donnes la salsa tu me donnes notoriété
et on va y aller et quand on allait
c'était en 2007 2008
c'était plutôt 2008 on a créé
l'association 2007 et on a fait le
lancement en 2008 on a dit voilà le
politirien convenance et à partie de la
côte d'ivoire va faire de ces de ce pays
quand même une plaque tournante des
belles lettres africaines
nous avons accueilli des sommités et
tout et puis nous allons le lauréat aura
la valeur numéraire à l'époque c'était
de 1 million et puis si les palos il
réside pas en côte d'ivoire nous allons
le faire venir le loger etc
alors je vous assure que les gens se
sont moqués de nous beaucoup dans la
salle qui les gens qui ont pris la
parole comme ça que nous on dit mais on
n'a pas besoin de re prix littéraire
c'est quoi c'est tout et c'est prix qui
n'est ceux qui vont mourir après il a
fallu il a fallu beaucoup de ténacité
face à la moquerie des gens parce que
même en dehors de la conférence de
presse dans le milieu les gens
voisine pas vu des choses changent voilà
donc il fallait faire fi de tout ça et
se dire bon et on va y aller quand même
retroussé les manches chercher des
financements chercher les contacts faire
un tel prix pour moi c'était important
qu'il faut que qu'on associe nos
devanciers
ceux là même qui ont fait la fierté de
nos belles lettres et donc il fallait
quelque part les invités en côte
d'ivoire lors de la remise de ce prix et
c'est ce qu'on a pu réussi à faire
c'était pas évident par exemple on
arrive au ps je suis allé trois fois à
paris dans le cadre de mon travail et
j'ai tout fait je m'accrochais de nuit
au salon du livre
je lui parlais mais dit d'accord
d'accord mais il est venu des personnes
comme seydou badian kouyaté digital
signal vraiment des sommités de la
littérature africaine
on a pu déplacer ici je pense que c'est
un rêve qui est devenu une réalité
au jour d'aujourd'hui ce prix littéraire
gagne en notoriété
on a beaucoup de plus en plus les
africains participe en envoyant leurs
ouvrages
on a vraiment cette année par exemple on
a reçu pratiquement une bonne
soixantaine d'ouvragés qui nous venaient
de partout parce que participer à ce
prix littéraire il faut écrire en
français donc peu importe si vous êtes
édité en europe ou même sur le continent
africain
donc on voit un véritable engouement à
la troisième édition du prix ivoire pas
il ya une dame qui vient de genève dit
je suis je viens de genève je veux
participer au prix ivoire elle participe
au prix ivoire elle repart à genève m
envoie une invitation et on a créé un
pont entre le salon du livre de genève
le salon africain du livre de genève et
le prix ivoire
c'est à dire que tous les lauréats du
prix ivoire sont systématiquement
invités à genève avec vraiment c'est une
très belle tribune
parce que vous avez des délais des
journalistes qui viennent de partout et
puis évidemment les lauréats du prix
ahmadou kourouma qui est décerné à la
fin
du salon du livre de genève nous les
invitons ici même en côte d'ivoire ce
prix littéraire j'aurais pu parce que
quand même j'avais une petite carrière
bon de communication pour la petite
histoire j'ai fait d'avoir des études
d'anglais et ensuite j'étais j'ai fait
des études de communication à
l'université mais je me suis dit qu'il
fallait que je passe quelque chose de
plus c'est en fait c'est l'amour que je
voulais donner si je voulais mettre en
lumière pas moi mais je voulais mettre
en lumière des auteurs palace yeux à
partir du continent et je vous assure
que cette démarche a rejailli sur ma
carrière professionnelle il faut que je
reconnaisse j'allais rester chargé de
communication là-bas assez d'un mais
convenance comment par exemple est venu
à diriger le groupe fraternité matin
si j'avais pas été fait ce qui libère je
pense qu'il n'avait pas pensé à moi ou
diriger la maison d'édition de l'état
donc de frat mat éditions
donc je profite de le remercier si je
n'avais pas fait ce prix littéraire vous
savez bientôt je dois partir je dois
représenter la côte d'ivoire il ya eu
une après un appel à candidatures de
l'onef récemment parce que la france va
être va être l'invité d'honneur au salon
du livre de francfort
c'est un très grand service
professionnel et donc la france a décidé
de venir avec en plus des éditeurs
français des éditeurs francophones et je
peux vous dire que je représente
l'afrique de l'ouest
j'ai participé comme sens bien mais je
suis sûr que c'est parce que je fais le
prix ivoire qui a une portée quelqu un
qu un cap qui m'a donné vraiment ce plus
là parce que il ya des éditeurs là
qu'ils ont dans leur catalogue beaucoup
plus d'ouvragés que moi que dans le
catalogue de frat mat éditions mais je
pense que le prix ivoire pour la
littérature africaine a milité en cette
faveur
donc je pars dans deux trois semaines à
paris après dans le cadre de cette
mission
on va préparer notre salon du livre
notre présence à francfort et donc on
part en allemagne avec des éditeurs
français jeu
je remercie dieu parce qu'il faut être
croyant j'avoue que les peaux de banane
du début jusqu'à la fin des
transpirations les incertitudes parce
que souvent on n'a pas toujours les
moyens
c'est un prix important qui mobilise
beaucoup de ressources je vais pas
dévoiler le budget ici parce qu'on sait
jamais donc mais c'est un prix qui
mobilise beaucoup de il faut mobiliser
beaucoup de ressources
je peux vous dire qu'à chaque prix il
voit on peut payer vilain mais voilà
donc je remercie tous ceux qui ont pu
nous accompagner dans ce rêve parce que
vraiment il fallait des gens pour nous
donner vraiment des moyens au début
c'était pas évident
à présent je veux je pense que je suis
dans le livre et j'adore la littérature
les mots mais parfois un les images
valent mille mots donc je voudrais que
vous m'aidiez la régie à papa c'est
maintenant ma présentation powerpoint
voilà donc c'est la suture parfois pas
que tu eux dirigés par les cadres on
était jeunes fougueux et plein d'espoir
là c'était le lancement on avait
emprunté 500 milles pour on avait rien
dans nos comptes
la première édition en 2008 ces
innovateurs kouyaté el semanal ndjock la
veuve de du cired été vains j'habite à
un signal à la deuxième édition
voilà que j'aime et que j'aimerai bien
renverser sur monsieur qui nous a donné
notre chance j'ai demandé lui ces
chaînes américaines voilà ça continue ça
c'est sûr le voir voilà monsieur salam
est très exigeant qui nous a poussé à
donner le meilleur de nous mêmes henri
lopes avec bernard dadié qui ne manquait
jamais pris ni veau et aucun prix ivoire
mais maintenant sa santé se dégrade j'ai
pu être officier du mérite culturel en
même temps que léonard groguhet vous
rendez compte
j'étais appellent bébé quand il faisait
voilà alain mabanckou qui a pu venir
aussi en 2000 tous la première dame nous
a reçus et nous reçoit très souvent
monsieur diététique j'aimerais vraiment
remercier aussi qui est un mécène comme
le directeur du livre ou un vrai c'est
ma maman
depuis le début m et soutien et puis
voilà maintenant le président
international qui est le parrain du prix
ivoire
amadou koné qui réside aux états unis
qui étaient survenus en côte d'ivoire
depuis plus de 20 ans alors voici la
lauréate cela tout lien lauréat du prix
ivoire
kelly mars c'est un très beau dîner gala
qui n'est pas du tout ennui je vous
invite à participer
là c'est au salon du livre de genève je
participe souvent en tant que
partenaires nous avons eu deux prix
d'excellence de la cedeao dans le
domaine culturel et je vous invite à
participer à la 9e édition du prix
ivoire qui aura lieu le 4 novembre
prochain je vaux m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]